[music]
with integrity, this is exactly what
damage is, if we’re watching on
TV, everyone knows where we live and in
ukraine, and on the other hand, I know that these are
peaceful people, that it’s impossible, well, how to try
not to hit, but here it’s aiming, that’s why we have already
lost all  the hope that we are someone
who is interested in our life there
[music]
simon shuvalov painted over but we won’t go
fly away to the basement of his daughter, he sold it at a gallop,
then he started to lie down at 40
minutes
[music]
no
there even after the war there will be people who have already
left many bought houses  we
won’t go there but it won’t be possible to live there
because they will have water
even papa water if the light turns off
we won’t be able to shop without light but it’s
very hard
[music]
there is hope we believe that someday it will be
established no more forever well  so only
at home they survived so that you live in this
situation, that is,
everything will be like that
[music]